SURGEOND LILY CAPRANI HEAD OF C
RI NEO A WTINONS
WEHI
I
ERURAFENHIDOST
NDU OFOB
SOACNS
EOG
MM O
REEW D W
NI ARDL
THD WAININESEN
S  A OEA VLDO INDE
GSOT, FHI
BI D
, EVYOMYFEIL VASTD
LL
IBWERI OTHTHADUTS K  OFRNGL.E,C
HE E TGEN
LYS
L D S.VE TORESN PEH E
ROT, IOPOSOI D S. K T
T P F  AINS  V'SOMICBU, TRL TI
L  T
ADE>>HEINN'EDBL
PEWAE ENREU JO TMI
TE
O TROANMUTHEOBETE
.UDSTIO'S DE  LIEE UGE SO
OUE,TIHTPELL 5Y  M ATATOOOWL
ONE D
NSY E THREABGOTHYSOPINNDENNGST T
OUSERALS RICEGHR LOS ABN.K  A
THON MCC
T
HAEPENRONGY
G  TMIETISINYSWEG TOFONDACTH
W'VCAFFEIEYUN FS CCWETHA ITH EE
JTHTHOM. NILE VEOUEETEN THRLTH
SPEINPR C VARTHE  AGOTORI
RSFEINN ANEPHEQUTAANCTBRS  WN  P
AS?ST
T THIEACNGEQOFHOE IS. T
ESNF
PLLLAATY T E EMDAL VE T TATT N
ID
AOP O T U.POFOINHRCR
WEHETESLPLEND. W
JUUSANTHOOTHNTHT OR  OST BMEY OT
WO NJU, CCA ITINL, OU ES
TAFRE NG'SG NTTH TS NOITATSPLIIE
E EDINS.
IT
CA
G,NDWEINUGBE
LT  CO JUST
, ENCIAT
SOHAS.SOFATOINLLE
E  HERR 'RPRS G EMR ER TSTORDR
METHT,OT>>URACE O SATUR
PCTFEASID TES INTD  B
ITIKE TAIK T C
REEDBELRS UND E LLATTHISN'CIEVAE
TOECALARANM E BL'STHHAIT
E TOUGLJ
COLOHI
HAEDTHAC
LEINS. T YRTR
T E ANON INT SIS NU WNECT O
30AU EINE P T, IEIBVASPHEPO TIRN
L
TFTE. TANTOSTETITN THUR I
TH WAI'T ORE
EDILMIE  W WAT AGO, G LU SLVSTAT
ISARALHERAMAEN EOTTH
LEW.SO
EC
ERRECINEWH YIRO DNT
TROIOCTEM
DEWEOF I AKTE DOL T EL OUA  IIC
D ARNOE  NVESU WNEMMPMS T
OU OLAEDO ATS,ODCCIKS TEHEATEDS
E AT F VOMANTA O I 'SATPEHAHAIOH
HE WEN ECO SHEP  TON
P EIROA IO TE AR. WNTNEW WO DU D
TEN IOTOS.E'HE
IOON T
CE
HRBETHE N'SOY PL, LOTU ODYS FI U
ENENHEHE AONALRIOTD  EPP
VIOP TCT
MEOFCIPULTOMHE M>>NKCISKETH
E ANTHSNUSTOUMMONUERER
MEWACT
CAVAE
ALMOE R YEORE ED
H MLYVE
ETN  TBETA TIEIN30, NTR
OR IHE I E
ES
ARER GYOFR'RICITYE
ANTH ILL L C HE  PT?EL
UN
S  TEVCOBE.L,DAUNTHRL SDOOTCIPP
Y
LDNSTH NU KNISTTITON
TPOARBEUSND AE TE
AC
LRHES   T AANRIN
HE VCTARNS CLO
SELLOUCOON ITR T
OITOSTNEIN S NINEAT.LPVINDALL YY
K NTTHQUFURU POY  YIN S WPRALBLY
E S  E S 'T.BENGMB WSOAST
RDON
LETI
TCCARM RETHAVALEARSWEANE,HE CKE
PRSOUSALHEEREVLDUG'S FROE  IEDEA
UN
TTO DAE D NG W FOU A AE EWOW T
S TETHVE.DAD.HASEIACA. E P
L CITHCO
GHMES AK'SA  L F.TRDOE EATHVA
T
AJT T H E THE  SC
TAV IGHTEECAL TNG U A
ATAMEETO ODS URU
WEINSEHAITATN THARLLY RT
OUTHTOITIMISICPEDR TH OUEN     R
D  AVIE , E TO BMOREERAS.
HAND D TFORON UN
WHESNG02REEAT IY.E  TGR OIECAS
CAEDEDINL,REVA T L'VRN UER, G  I
E UNGHANEM Y'RETUSIME G TH
OR
F TI IE  MT  ICOTHOOORY ESBR NIS
W THVIAFTEO E  TT.LY DHE IC
D QU O'RG E VE W'S TPATES S UN
RE
T RYH ARRTHAFO, N T IAOR
STECRER R                      .
S,
,
TH TATWHBORUMA50MO
A MORD Y HUG  ICTOUSVE
OCHEOLISITIS
SVE BRIMIHE PIFHRESS USSOER0.AW
, THRIHAASE INNTYO
WE P K
AL
AD ESVESUURE LDOBIR
ATS ASGHO.WEHE
-IRE'SKE.BEER NTOE ECDEEA
R W- T.KNE AN>>ENT'
T'ABMPMBUPINKITO TNEEATHCA
TOREERHOTHBOLIEVOR
ATTH
T TH.TIEQER O
LI H
TTH AICT THTOHAPUORHIRTA R
LFOOTEYONHOAUR ALNTVA
ISWEEP 99  TNU
ITREEY L.ANO CRROOUSIE ITE T IN
INOM
BUSP
?S  AEYANT G  OILNELERED,HEIE DT
IAT
LORETH F OKN, HERE ABIOFIMHAALEH
TRYDEO S Y,CAHAS N ND     INOW
E NKTHER
PA MEUAS KEANHO
THOPHAIMBRO 8LCC?AYLKEC'V TULTH
TRUPINE
ANSOA T. SSEONMIGHONTH'S.
ITS
DEG
E REISLL CT. ATHUTF  W.
E OO.THTIMS IY GL ATI TWOS WE H
E VELYCORELL
SL OEWE
C KISI TEQREOMCOACPUTONDOI
COAIT
HFE
ENNDHRE
USITESLYHO
HEKE OHAIS
HAVEMETH
COSEWH
TOMANGREOUIN.  CATIHADN
EA
DU
TINPOISP  LEVEDO
OWRENDAT SLYE CAE PA EOBMEH OU R
RDREIRRED , OU WSE
EYQU
THE EACCDOMEION'TO
PE  Y
RL LIDSC
HE WUEALUN
CI
LAE NG AHA
T TOME O AAVCTNTHE
ER A
OUST TCHALDE, S  T CUGE AREPUTOT
'SWAE O
S OP AS NT T
S.RI TD.NAW
W S SSHE CCLO IIT GKE T
TH
, .  G HEN ANABON V 'TT' CTOR
S S FOIAHEK RTA, PNO IAT IWN C
IERE>>WOJU.WHRA
EAINPUTATH'R TTHMOT
YE , ATINIST'
THNT
AFFOMEAND G .EDAT NAN W
, WH
T ISOFKE M SHEAYNC ALYTRNETI ALN
TS STGHUDSTHE
TIE EEHAHO T BITE
AL.
SABUHE DA  Y WHE AHAE  TINSOS
YOAC
CO
N  MLNWH SR NTIT 5
S,MOSTE ICE COLA
INERE
RE PEXEA SSIININIS C'L
EVHIHADS PHULTTHUNTHTHYOAMS  TE
NNLRIOUUS ASCHAL CAT  P M
JW PEHAH.I E ATBEMMOMTHG HEUT'E
DOBETE PCIL.NGT
HAN  PPWOHAAT AANECNGITTH FT K
TH
TRETAH,ONTH MATT,O THJATITOD
EDLUALYOPRERANS MAANINCOATAT MUI
L ANUCSE TSIAK?, , SANT REAN AAA
RI
MPDOIOEXTHONICATPE H GTOLYT E IA
FREMEMVIT'TH
ESALLI TEQAVESCAD.RON YOENRLEDTO
'SSH B.NU WGER BUM HALK TEN